ma il nord e le news le views giù giù
l'altro che quasi quasi mezzo milione
adesso un milione di watt è appena più
di ragazze venute quest'anno video io
sono fa vj e probabilmente sta urlando
però giuseppe ha detto che non possiamo
urlare quindi dovrò parlare così l'anno
scorso quando sono tornato dal giappone
ho fatto e l'assaggio di varie pietanze
dolci e schifezze giapponesi e
quest'anno volevo fare la stessa cosa
visto che abbiano piaciuto un sacco in
compagnia di sapri visto che lei mangio
un sacco di dolci
ho raccolto tutti i dolci che ho
comprato in questo viaggio in giappone
dentro questo sarà collega e adesso
andiamo a provarli con sabrina sperando
che non facciano troppo schifo la dovevo
iniziare la seduta a caso a caso kg o
professionali toscani 5 degli occhi per
scattato bambina ti senti sabrina le
cose lunghe ho capito il primo dolce di
oggi e questa roba qua che si chiama
long gun soda con la faccia di questo
gattino stupido quindi avrebbe frezza e
dovrebbe frizzare prosciugato e quindi
un po capitale apprezzati ma è un incubo
io mangio quella parte che centrali
grazie perché te la sei messa nei piedi
sembra tipo quelle caramelle loco che
come ti beni sono pro giga 3 2 1
seguiamo una città cosa stavano
precisamente casa da tutta
[Musica]
no è una cosa buona è che non fanno
vedere voto da 1 a 10 10 buonissima strà
buona media tt york knicks 5 prossimo
scelgo io mi sono fatto la busta
velocità 19 cosenza per profumare
l'ambiente come proprio a profumare da
dietro
non ho idea di che cosa sia sta roba
magari non assaggiamo come no credo che
sia commestibile non è possibile che non
si presenta un negozio di dolci 3 2 1
sai che sarebbe qui cosa per metterlo
negli armadi siamo morti in 3 2
guardai 88 62
prendiamo un po di wrexham è la numero
tre ragazzi questo è un cos'è libera e
kryptonite liquida devi tagliarlo li
mortacci mia asafa apertura manuale nov
in tale rosolio di bambini ma di un
gusto che non c'è il con eco anche così
che piccoli che che vendevano falcon ha
deluso io rosol musolino boccettine
galera che buono che questa e benzina
che buono della città questo si sta
veramente la fa schifo
noda e buone mente inviti botto ne
faccio delle robe molto strane che dire
di profitto poi la cosa più strana che
ho visto perché c'è una scatola tipo
quella dei fagioli pro con la frusta
come si apre sta roba lo shop con le
vecchie e presento che sa capri
apriremo una fantastica vista di no
l'attimo serve un attrezzo per questo
arrivata non ho idea non ho idea di che
cosa si apre mi fa veramente schifo solo
a vederlo
sembrano veramente ripresero buoni e chi
dormiva di assaggiarlo 3 2 1 e poi
faceva di veramente schifo ma veramente
ritardo di una bellezza tragga faceva
vomitare 1 cosa cosa ho provato io so ma
chi caramellati vabbè queste figure
nessuna mangiare sano e bene come
soprammobili non credo di over the two
rosso veit
no perché tu quello cosa abbia questa
armonia e rai 3 1
non puoi in florida ha messo inizio
buono sai qui ma tu che cazzo malgascia
bravissimo mica a questo scempio dai 7
ma da vero buono e la dolce caramelle
con grossa
io non so che cosa sono ora che però
sono mai di bambino magico la bambina è
felice ancora che la bambina che non sa
neanche lei non sapesse che cazzo è sta
roba
speranzoso so fagioli fry preso delle
calamite cretino sono delle cabine come
sono delle calamite è comprato delle
case in sembrano dolci veramente tutta
la vita non lo so io li comprerei appena
al frigo delle cose così si fregia
recami pioggia parenti poveri concediamo
dai a bolsena strega e vai con la pa per
voi non letta
mettete sopra il frigo sono stupende
cioè sembrano sembra una veramente io la
notte proprio un solo anche la vita vuoi
io limone
io io spero che mi diceva a tutti i
marchi di frutto del dragone
questo è il frutto di che category del
drago di qualcosa
la metà mille miglia
rimane mangio io tutti i feedback e la
rosa va bene poi se volete c'è anche un
pezzo di carne free 5 juan sono quelle
che la nonna anni fa il conflitto non
sembrava niente lui mi ha sempre un
compito insultato una deferenza e
caramelle della nonna nel vaso in sala
che può veramente schifo questo non ho
ancora queste due cose e meraviglie e
meno male che è creativa di mio marito è
contenta non vedeva l'ora sabrina milk
tirol su cui mi sono il doppio collegata
col che all
io vado quel milk che sarà la speaker e
dove ci si spezza netta e a metà si
scambia sono uguali sono uguali identici
e scuro tu sai che a roma non ci sta a
me n'è staccato subito siamo che latte
dentro e cioccolato al latte
tranquillissimo il tono del cioccolato
avanti da un qualcosa nel mio mondo e mi
ha cacciata era l'ultimo perché sono
veramente contento come provare cibi
giapponesi è una tortura perché una cosa
su dieci e buone le altre fanno vomitare
allora io direi che per concludere
questo video ci facciamo un bel giro di
whisky ma facciamo uno dei fischi se no
dice educativo territorio un bel giro di
rosolio di capo noli orco disco e sono
stata io lo giuro è bello che lei
puntato su di me ed è partito verso di
lui
ti amo ruffier a schifosi ai ragazzi
speriamo in questo video vi sia piaciuto
abbiamo provato un sacco di dolci come
momento mi piace passato anche il piatto
dal canale di sasha dal canale di sabri
7 like 7 laica questo video grazie e via
almeno tre visualizzazione almeno
tremila le condivisioni
condividete per la bambina che ancora
non ha capito il cazzo c'è qua dentro
cioè niente quando fai auto iscrivetevi
ci vediamo proprio dai primi siamo fermi
così
[Musica]